on va parler de tout ça interview vérité
initial initiale le vas-y aulas quelle
connerie tu es contente toi maintenant
que javier l est
javier est en larmes
alors donc effectivement vous noté dans
votre pipe de parennes entre les
événements politiques et l'exécution de
tapis vous dit quand je lisais les
sondages je savais que nos ennuis
judiciaires s'amplifierait mais tapie
avait une faiblesse il se croyait
invulnérable
tout le monde connaît tapis de l'époque
de la grande époque
pete est un homme puissant souvenez vous
quand même dommage invraisemblable et
extraordinaire du président la
république avait un tapis en pleine
affaire om verdun mais monsieur
mitterrand fait un hommage appuyé ben
ali monsieur pierre mauroy dit tout ce
qui est bon pour l'om est bon pour le ps
a fait c'est quand même des choses fort
mais ça vous vous sentez alors vas voir
toute l'histoire donc avant lorraine
êtes les études supérieures de gestion
de finance de management et vous
commencez votre carrière dans des grands
groupes puis vous devenez consultant et
puis vous rentrez à l'om pourquoi
aimanté par tapie facilement la vie
j'aimerais que chacun se souvient de ce
qu'était tapis pour les années 88
ouais c'était un radieux de la
communication il avait son émission
ambitions il avait fait son livre gagner
tout le monde le cite en exemple comme
un jeune entreprise
donc pour moi qui avait des ambitions de
faire aussi les affaires dans le futur
je venais près du pape de l'autre refuse
absolument
alors il y avait aussi d'algos qu'il est
très sympa très sympa à jouer là vous
travaillez dur de rentrer à l'om c'est
c'est difficile mais vous donner
beaucoup de mal vous travaillez sur les
droits télé sur les loges vip et les
sponsors
le merchandising premier problème en
1990 donc il ya deux ans vous êtes là
vous êtes entendus pour une histoire de
transfert les transferts de leu métal
pardo qui venait de toulon et là où
passer une nuit en taule déjà on vous
demande à vous aimez vous n'êtes pas
quoi oui bah c'est pas c'est pas la
taule c'est la garde à vue ça arrive
avec l'homme à tout le monde je voudrais
dire c'est tout ce qui m'est arrivé peut
arriver à tout le monde
la garde à vue c'est les policiers qui
viennent me gêne pas pour nous ouais
c'est là c'est très pervers y viennent
pour une affaire concernant toulon le
transfert de olmeta pardoe casoni et
dans la discussion bernès a signé
l'autorisation policiers
aurizon a vérifié les comptes de l'om tu
en as quand même
et là effectivement on nous pose
beaucoup de questions mais je réponds ce
que j'ai répondu moi j'ai pas changé et
pourtant je subis des pressions a dansé
pendant cette garde à vue et je tiens
mes positions
et depuis cette date là j'ai pas à
varier d'une seule subi un recul de tout
ce que j'ai toujours dit depuis cette
garde à vue alors l'om marche à l'om
connaît beaucoup de succès malgré tout
ya des problèmes avec vigouroux le maire
de marseille vous met des bâtons dans
les roues d'une façon assez systématique
chaque fois qu'il peut pas écouter
c'était flagrant
monsieur vigouroux avait le talent de
faire le contraire de ce qu'on proposait
comme ça marchait une dizaine inverse
ouais alors puis à la ferme au mba c'est
à dire on retrouve deux cent cinquante
mille francs en espèces dans le jardin
de la tante de glassman périgueux qui
vit voilà qui dit bernet smac corrompu
il m'a demandé de lever le pied
ouais l'écouté mais d'abord j'ai pas été
mis en examen dans cette affaire dont
nous je peux en parler qu'avec une
certaine distance ce que je sais c'est
qu'il n'y a aucun lien qui a été prouvé
entre les preuves matérielles présenté
notamment l'argent puisque ses preuves
matérielles
non aucun aucune empreinte non aucune
les billets ne correspondent pas des
billets qui viennent de marseille
la police a fait les investigations
énorme et croyez moi aussi j'avais
trouvé quelque chose j'aurais été
forcément bien dans les âmes un mois
c'est 1 ça reste une grande affaire
extrêmement douteuse troublante car on
me fait pas croire qu'un joueur de
football qui sont qui dépensent quand
même pas mal d'argent puis saint matin
trois semaines après ressortir une somme
d'argent comme ça et comme par hasard ça
se passe le jour où j'annonce la
lancement de la création d'une société
extrêmement importante et l'om 1er 1er
voilà où j'avais réuni plus de 300 chefs
d'entreprise locaux ainsi que cinq
investisseurs de dimension
internationale j'avais réuni 100
millions de francs qui avait pour objet
de rentrer dans le capital de l'om et
d'autre part d'aider des entreprises
régionales à se développer comme par
hasard comme bayard immense moment cet
argent dans le jardin de la tante de
glace m'a pourri gâté rigueur la sphère
om premier qui était très prometteuse
effectivement ne se fait pas élire la
police des coupes votre coffre fort au
chat l'humour pas c'est abominable je
trouve un bureau mais sa cage et pour
vous c'est un coup monté
berne et ses complices on me dit je veux
dire moi je crois que le pays de la
sphère de mba est une affaire totalement
monté à partir du moment où aucune des
pièces
aucun des aucun des éléments qui
concerne l'om sont avérées faut bien
savoir que les joueurs de valenciennes
ne met pas en cause ni l'om ni tapis
bettencourt super nes et puis j'ai quand
même fait troublant bernès jusqu'à roues
jusqu'au procès a toujours soutenu qu'il
avait été piégé
je me rappelle un truc que tout le monde
a oublié c'est lui qui dépose plainte
le premier contre les dirigeants de
valenciennes pour avoir lui-même été
comme corrompu donc faut pas oublier ça
c'est bien mais ce qui le dépose plainte
en tout premier le 4 juillet c'est pas
valence est ne s'est pas la ligue si
bernès et jusqu'au procès qui soutient
sa il écrit même un livre qui
directement ce et le jour du procès
comme par hasard il fait exploser le
disant complètement autre chose
il ya un manque de cohérence quand même
parce que tapie maintenant quand il
rencontre bernès dans un restaurant il
change de restaurants où il demande que
berné journal c'est quand même le succès
des gammes pas pardonné c'est quand même
son inspiration donc le menace kibet en
capital en prison je suis allé en prison
sur les déclarations peu mal quand même
près alors en 1994
bah effectivement il ya un sondage dans
vsd il ya même un photomontage où
bernard tapie était bien au président de
la république et on dit ben voilà s'il y
avait des élections présidentielles
entre chirac et tapis tapie aurait 46 %
et chirac 54 donc d'un seul coup il
devient sans doute effectivement je veux
dire pour un certain nombre de barons de
la gauche devient l'homme à abattre
et là tout est à faire le tour de sully
à au mba on vient d'en parler il
yal'affaire des comptes de l'om
et puis après il ya le phocéa testud etc
oui mais très fort voir ce qui se passe
je crois que c'est dans ce livre dont je
l'écris j'avais peur même en l'écrivant
lui sera possible on pas tout ça dans la
tête n'y a pas que ça on veut nous faire
déposer le bilan au ciel ouvert on nous
met en examen c'est en 94 qu'on ait mis
en examen tout à l'heure vous avez dit
on est en garde à vue en 90 qu'est ce
qui se passe entre 90 à 94 rien non
seulement il se passe rien contre nous
dire que finalement ce qui était dit en
90 par la police n'est pas s'il n'y a
pas eu de suite sur la terre et aucune
suit la zone i pardo olmeta web et sur
ce qu'on nous reproche que l'on reproche
plein de choses qui vont ressortir
quatre ans après les affaires de
de transfert de moser 2 et terme à tout
ça ressort après alors à l'époque donc
tapis devient incontournable sur le plan
politique effectivement après les
européennes mais il est aussi par contre
là donc c'est le début de la la lie et
vous notez d'ailleurs effectivement les
convergences des faits sur des périodes
très concentré exemple alors là on voit
la fin octobre 94 vous rencontrez un
investisseur pour l'om qui prêt à
financer le club qui est prêt à investir
dans le club et qui vous fait nettement
comprendre qu'en échange il voudrait
quand même quelques informations sur la
tapis wii passe à puce et puis c'est
plus pervers c'est à dire que ces
investisseurs étaient pas un
investisseur c'était un émissaire qui
m'a demandé clairement de prière tapis
ouais c'est à dire qu'on fait là chers
amis je suis le seul qui ait jamais
trahi et c'est justement j'y suis né je
n'ai pas trahi alors cet ami ça me dit
quoi
il me dit que c'est lui qui nous a
laissé il n'y aura pas de problème pour
vous en matière pénale si vous me dites
des choses importantes est bon et on est
en pleine période d'avant prix d'avant
élections et c'est tros amusant parce
qu'on est en gros six mois que cinq mois
avant les élections
bernès sans avocat à ce moment là tiens
c'est curieux
moi on me propose de travailler et
quinze jours après mais on en ce
contrôle judiciaire avec interdiction de
travailler la nuit il se passe beaucoup
de choses et fait infiniment à la
brévine conneries comme dans toute cette
affaire monsieur je vous ai monté une
société avec kara georgis donc l'agent
de l'om
bon une société qui n'a jamais travaillé
une société en qui est restée en sommeil
mais c'est sûr que le juge philippon ça
vous a pas rendu crédible à ses yeux
mais julien je lui ai tendu à cenon à
une perte énorme d'abord c'est moi qui
lui dit au juge c'est pas lui qui le
tour ouais et moi spontanément parce que
je pensais pas qu'il y avait vraiment
péril en la demeure
belleville pensait que cette société
xavier montet avec kara georgis est en
fait une planque pour une caisse noire
de l'om bien sûr ils me disent pas
possible tout le monde
elle se passe alors faisons tout le
monde soit au courant parce qu'on avait
des proférées contre eux on avait des
commissaires aux comptes des double
signature
je dis non c'est un truc personnel
j'assume je vais pas raconter comme gut
c'est à pisser mois la russie fait ça et
pourquoi vous parce que j'avais envie de
faire du commerce comme je suis dans le
livre mon but c'est après que c'est
autre chose que l'eau c'est le web ça
après un stress énorme bond puis je
serai notre pays bernard tapie bien sûr
je laime c'est un homme merveilleux
mais je crois que la main traille seul à
l'aimer et de la palma il a fait un
disque en sort avec lui donc ouais c'est
clair j'ai envie de faire autre chose
mais le juge rue la sueur j avais le
choix le juge il me dit soit c'est pour
vous à titre privé puis je vous poursuit
pour abus soit c'est pour l'ol smic et
noir ont été enterrés 15 etc dans tous
les cas j'étais eu lim tenait bien est
un sas éclairage et en tous les cas
j'essaie justement on va parler des
juges philippe on chez vous vous était à
lumière et ici aussi à la roche
est-ce que vous jurer aujourd'hui que le
juge philippe on vous a promis un
assouplissement de votre sort
si vous balancier bernard tapie
absolument j'ai subi des pressions de
toutes natures et puis toute la
procédure qui a suivi le juge philippe
on a largement démontré que c'était pour
mettre une pression pour me faire avouer
quelque chose donc il y avait un
chantage
manifestement c'est un chantage aux
femmes extrêmement violent mais c'est un
chantage au régime
effectivement à la roche là on vous met
en prison d'abord on vous met à l'évêché
pendant dix heures sans boire et sans
manger dont vous découvrez effectivement
la dure vie des prisonniers vous sépare
très importante dans votre livre c'est
très touchant la façon dont vous en
parlez apprend vous mais aux baumettes
sans prévenir votre famille
bah c'est l'enfer le pire moment ça a
était quoi d'abord tabac on comprend
rien du tout parce que ça me j'avais
pris un coup de poing dans la figure
j'étais complètement ko ce n'est
heureusement que j'ai eu les ressources
morales au delà de la normale parce que
sinon on peut mourir il ya des gens là
suicide pour moins que ça donc c'est
très dur en permanence et puis je ne
savais pas ce qui allait se passer quand
vous êtes en prison pour trois mois six
mois plus dense et vous nous organiser
n'oubliez pas également que j'étais
incarcéré contre l'avis du procureur
c'est quand même dingue
en 1995 un simple juge d'instruction un
homme peut vous mettre en prison
sur sa seule décision contre l'avis du
procureur je voudrais insister là dessus
en plus je suis peut-être seul français
rentre en prison pour avoir avoir payé
pour entrer en prison j'ai payé ma
caution la veille meilleures entreprises
ont enfin c'est des choses incroyables
quand on nous raconte alors c'était dur
tous les jours
bien sûr mais c'était surtout surtout
dur quand je devais vois ma femme ou
parloir parce que là c'est l'humiliation
pour isoler la pression aussi ils ont
menacé votre femme de la mettre en
examen tous mais tous mes amis tous mes
proches ont été entendus avec des
pressions ma femme effectivement a subi
elle même des fortes pressions allant
très très loin il est évidente dans le
livre j'en parle mais quelque part j'ai
encore de l'humilité il a pu leur parler
parce que quand je la voyais puis que je
sais mais ce qu'on lui faisait dehors
c'était terrible alors autre pression
vous êtes confrontés à berne est sûre
les matches achetés vous vous dites non
à ma connaissance il appelle de deux
matches achetés alors est ce que il y en
a pas eu des matches achetés ou est-ce
que vous ne saviez pas qu'il y en a eu
quand je parle de ce que je sais c'est à
dire que tapie ne m'a jamais dit la
roche
il faut organiser un tel show telle
chose pourrait donc les rumeurs j'en ai
entendu des centaines
je n'ai jamais eu d'instruction jamais
eu un ordre pour fait l'accord en sorte
voilà voilà
alors philippe on le juge philippe ont
donc vous faire craquer vous craquez pas
justement est-ce que vous craquez pas
parce que vous n'avez rien à dire ou
parce que vous êtes très fort
mentalement
il faut d'abord être très fort
mentalement parce qu'on peut dire
n'importe quoi
ouais vous savez qu'il ya des gens qui
disent n'importe quoi qui avoue n'a fait
ce qui est peut-être arrivée adil
souhaitent tous les actes que j'ai
accompli j'ai accompli en conscience et
usa corp +1 conscience parce que je
pensais que c'était nécessaire pour le
club c'était dans l'intérêt
d'entreprises et que j'avais pris toutes
les précautions de vérification auprès
des avocats des conseils du ministre du
budget lui la justice la ligue et parce
que c'est des pratiques connues dans le
football c'est tout donc je vais pas le
sentiment de faire des choses va
abominable savez quand on est quand on
voit lui l'arrêt de la cour d'appel
on se dit mais c'est pas possible qu'on
vous ait fait ça justement un jour avoir
un jour de novembre
vous vous retrouvez seul en tenue d'été
devant la porte des baumettes et c'est
un gardien qui vous raccompagne à
marseille
votre femme n'avait pas été prévenue
dans l'administration pénitentiaire de
votre retour
alors après le procès vous prenez de la
prison avec sursis dont vous découvrez à
ce moment là vous avez fait 5 mois et
quelques mois une semaine de prison
ferme pour rien
rien n'est fait cinq mois une semaine
faisons absolument pour rien mais
attendez moi j'ai une question simple à
la si vous avez été condamnée même à de
la prison avec sursis et à deux cent
mille francs d'amendé
oui il ya quand même quelque part une
culpabilité je lui ment mais je conteste
pas jusqu'à les votre culpabilité alors
je l'expliquais c'est quand même
important de savoir qu'on était condamné
ben oui pourquoi est ce qu ont été
compilées pour trois raisons 1 ont fait
des prêts aux joueurs deuxième shorin
joueurs deuxièmement les contrats
d'image
les joueurs m'ont déjà des images comme
une vedette de cinéma où on était et le
troisième point c'est les appelle ça le
football c'est à présent plus petite
part du dos et ont payé les commissions
les impôts c'est le football pourquoi
pour faciliter les transferts pour avoir
des renseignements confidentiels sur des
clubs c'est ce que tous les clubs font
entendre
voilà les trois raisons c'est pas les
choses qui sont graves c'est des choses
qui sont allés discutable bien donc vous
avait été pris dans les rouages d'une
opération de déstabilisation politique
j'ai été pris parce que j'ai pris une
position loyal je suis quelqu'un qui a
cette vertu est une vertu c'est un
défaut parfois peut-être mais en tout
cas c'est la mienne à la recharge mot à
dire bernard tapie ce soir vous regardez
votre caméra vous lui dites quoi majidi
bonjour parce que je n'ai pas revu
depuis pas mal de temps et bon courage
parce que la sphère va être difficile
j'espère que l'on va réussir et j'ai
peut-être quelques conseils à lui donner
et un mauvais fonctionnement financier
écrit business un moa verdez chacun fait
sa vie on est maître de son destin
j'ai choisi mais ma voix ce que je sais
c'est que quand je me regarde je suis en
harmonie avec moi-même et je peux parler
en face avec tout le monde je regarde le
monde dans les yeux et je suis fier par
rapport à mai simplement mes gosses mais
aussi par rapport aux marseillais et aux
supporters marseillais d'avoir fait ce
que j'ai fait pour un grand club que
j'aime encore voilà la ville et le rêve
la vérité voilà